la magie qui a enchanté des générations
arrivent enfin sur grand écran magique
l'amitié et les poneys exclusivement au
cinéma
et maintenant voici la touche
my little pony le film avec une chanson
originale de shia le 18 octobre au
cinéma
génial je suis la princesse twilight
sparkle et voici mon royaume equestria
un pays plein de magie de musique aux
yeux est le plus important d'amitié la
vie est parfaite
qu'est-ce qui pourrait aller de travers
c'est sans sûrement les plus que j'ai
regardé
o comme ça c'est sûr vous n'êtes pas les
clowns que j'ai engage à l'âne
l'audi des quatre favoris la commandante
telle pression commencions par une
reddition complète et définitive
on vient de recevoir de capter du pk7
que j'ai jamais vu bon homme poisson
s'est fait jeter c'est du gâteau
j'adore le gâteau
[Musique]
on a besoin des aides pour sauver
equestria ce qui nous arrive
trempez là maintenant
oh
vimont nous mêmes je suis la seule à
appliquer c'est moi que tu aimes tu veux
mais nous sommes ensemble montrons à ces
petits poneys comment il faut faire
l'amitié les fleurs les jolis pots lait
et boulay
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais tu reviens pas de stress
heureusement j'ai des amis formidables
qui sont là pour moi quoi qu'il arrive
[Musique]
pink il ya du gâteau en visuel visuel
confirmés ont fait le ménage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
my little pony le fil exclusivement au
cinéma le 18 octobre